this is america's day
this is democracy's day a day of history
and hope
of renewal and resolve through a
crucible
for the ages america has been tested
anew
and america has risen to the challenge
today we celebrate the triumph not of a
candidate
but of a cause the cause of democracy
the people the will of the people
has been heard and the will of the
people has been heeded
we've learned again that democracy is
precious
democracy is fragile this hour my
friends
democracy has prevailed
so now on this hallowed ground were just
a few days ago
violence sought to shake the capital's
very foundation
we come together as one nation under god
indivisible to carry out the peaceful
transfer of power as we have for more
than two centuries
as we look ahead in our uniquely
american way
restless bold optimistic
and set our sights on the nation we know
we can
be and we must be
i thank my predecessors of both parties
for their presence here today
i thank them from the bottom of my heart
and i know
and i know the resilience of our
constitution
and the strength the strength of our
nation
as does president carter who i spoke
with last night who cannot be with us
today
but whom we salute for his lifetime in
service
i've just taken the sacred oath each of
those patriots
have taken the oath first sworn
by george washington but the american
story
depends not on any one of us not on some
of us
but on all of us on we
the people who seek a more perfect union
this is a great nation we are good
people
and over the centuries through storm and
strife
in peace and in war we've come so far
but we still have far to go
we'll press forward with speed and
urgency for we have much to do
in this winter of peril and significant
possibilities
much to repair much to restore
much to heal much to build and much to
gain
few people in our nation's history have
been more challenged
or found a time more challenging or
difficult
than the time we're in now once in a
century virus
that silently stalks the country has
taken as many lives in one year
as america lost in all of world
war ii millions of jobs have been lost
hundreds of thousands of businesses
closed
a cry for racial justice some 400 years
in the making
moves us the dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer
a cry for survival comes from planet
itself
a cry that can't be any more desperate
or any more clear and now
a rise of political extremism white
supremacy
domestic terrorism that we must confront
and we will defeat
to overcome these challenges to restore
the soul and secure the future of
america
requires so much more than words
requires the most elusive of all things
in a democracy
unity unity
in another january on new year's day in
1863
abraham lincoln signed the emancipation
proclamation
when he put pen to paper the president
said and i quote
if my name ever goes down into history
it'll be for this act and my whole
soul is in it
my whole soul is in it today
on this january day my whole soul is in
this
bringing america together uniting our
people
united in our nation and i ask every
american to join me
in this cause
uniting to fight the foes we face
anger resentment and hatred extremism
lawlessness violence disease
joblessness and hopelessness with unity
we can do great things important things
we can right wrongs we can put people to
work in good jobs we can teach our
children in safe schools we can overcome
the deadly virus we can reward
reward work and rebuild the middle class
and make health care secure for all
we can deliver racial justice and we can
make america once again
the leading force for good in the world
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like
a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart
the battle is perennial and victory is
never assured
through civil war the great depression
world war 9 11
through struggle sacrifice and setbacks
our better angels
have always prevailed
in each of these moments enough of us
enough of us
have come together to carry all of us
forward
and we can do that now history
faith and reason show the way
the way of unity we can see each other
not as adversaries but as neighbors
we can treat each other with dignity and
respect
we can join forces stop the shouting and
lower the temperature
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury no progress
only exhausting outrage no nation
only a state of chaos this is our
historic moment
of crisis and challenge and unity
is the path forward and we must meet
this moment
as the united states of america
if we do that i guarantee you we will
not fail
we have never ever ever ever failed in
america
when we've acted together and so today
at this time in this place let's start
afresh
all of us let's begin to listen to one
another again
hear one another see one another
show respect to one another politics
doesn't have to be a raging fire
destroying everything in his path
every disagreement doesn't have to be a
cause for total war
and we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufactured
my fellow americans we have to be
different than this
america has to be better than this and i
believe america is so much better than
this just look around
here we stand in the shadow of the
capitol dome
as was mentioned earlier completed amid
the civil war
when the union itself was literally
hanging in the balance
yet we endured we prevailed
here we stand looking out on the great
mall
where dr king spoke of his dream
here we stand we're 108 years ago
at another inaugural thousands of
protesters tried to block
brave women marching for the right to
vote
and today we mark the swearing-in of the
first woman in american history
elected to national office vice
president kamala harris
don't tell me things can't change
here we stand across the potomac from
arlington cemetery
where heroes who gave the last full
measure of devotion
rest in eternal peace and here we stand
just days after a riotous mom thought
they could use violence to silence the
will of the people
to stop the work of our democracy to
drive us from this sacred ground
it did not happen it will never happen
not today not tomorrow not ever
not ever
all those who supported our campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
the right to dissent peaceably then the
guard rails of our republic is perhaps
this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to disunion
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and i promise you i will fight as hard
for those who did not support me
as for those who did
[Applause]
many centuries ago saint augustine
a saint of my church wrote that a people
was a multitude
defined by the common objects of their
love
defined by the common objects of their
love
what are the common objects we as
americans love
that define us as americans i think we
know
opportunity security
liberty dignity respect honor
and yes the truth
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies told for power and for profit
and each of us has a duty and a
responsibility
as citizens as americans and especially
as leaders
leaders who have pledged to honor our
constitution
and protect our nation to defend the
truth
and defeat the lies look
i understand that many of my fellow
americans view the future
was fear and trepidation i understand
they worry about their jobs
i understand like my dad they lay at bed
staring at the
night staring at the ceiling wondering
can i keep my health care
can i pay my mortgage thinking about
their families
about what comes next i promise you i
get it
but the answer is not to turn inward to
retreat into competing factions
distrusting those who don't look like
look like you
or worship the way you do or don't get
their news from the same sources you do
we must end this uncivil war
that pits red against blue
rural versus ireland or rural versus
urban
conservative versus liberal we can do
this
if we open our souls instead of
hardening our hearts
if we show a little tolerance and
humility
and if we're willing to stand in the
other person's shoes as my mom would say
just for a moment stand in their shoes
because here's the thing about life
there's no accounting for what fate will
deal you
some days when you need a hand
there are other days when we're called
to lend a hand
that's how it has to be it's what we do
for one another
and if we are this way our country will
be stronger
more prosperous more ready for the
future
and we can still disagree my fellow
americans
and the work ahead of us we're going to
need each other
we need all our strength to preserve to
persevere
through this dark winter we're entering
what may be
the toughest and deadliest period of the
virus
we must set aside politics and finally
face this pandemic as
one nation one nation
and i promise you this as the bible says
weeping may endure for a night but joy
cometh in the morning we will get
through this
together together
look folks all my colleagues i serve
with
in the house and the senate up here
we all understand the world is watching
watching all of us today so here's my
message to those beyond our borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
and will lead not merely by the example
of our power but by the power of
our example
we'll be a strong and trusted partner
for peace
progress and security
look you all know we've been through so
much in this nation
and my first act as president i'd like
to ask you to join me
in a moment of silent prayer remember
all those who have lost in this past
year to the pandemic
those four hundred thousand fellow
americans moms
dads husbands wives sons daughters
friends neighbors and co-workers
we'll honor them by becoming the people
and the nation
we know we can and should be so i ask
you
let's say a silent prayer for those
who've lost their lives and those left
behind
and for our country
amen folks
this is a time of testing we face an
attack under democracy
and on truth a raging virus
growing inequity the sting of systemic
racism
a climate in crisis america's role in
the world
any one of these would be enough to
challenge us in profound ways
but the fact is we face them all at once
presenting this nation with the one of
the greatest responsibilities we've had
now we're going to be tested are we
going to step up
all of us it's time for boldness
for there's so much to do and this is
certain
i promise you we will be judged
you and i by how we resolve these
cascading crises of our era
we will rise to the occasion is the
question will we
master this rare and difficult hour
when we meet our obligations and pass
along a new and better world to our
children
i believe we must i'm sure you do as
well i believe we will
and when we do we'll write the next
great chapter
in the history of the united states of
america the american story
a story that might sound something like
a song that means a lot to me
it's called american anthem
there's one verse that stands out
at least for me and it goes like this
the work and prayers of century have
brought us to this day
what shall be our legacy what will our
children say
let me know in my heart when my days are
through
america america i gave my best to you
let's add let's us add our own work and
prayers
to the unfolding story of our great
nation
if we do this then when our days are
through
our children and our children's children
will save us
they gave their best they did their duty
they healed the broken land
my fellow americans i closed the day
where i began
with the sacred oath before god and all
of you
i give you my word i will always level
with you
i will defend the constitution i'll
defend our democracy
i'll defend america and i'll give
all all of you keep
everything you i do in your service
thinking not of power but of
possibilities not a personal interest
but the public good
and together we shall write an american
story
of hope not fear of unity not division
of light
not darkness a story of decency and
dignity
love and healing greatness and goodness
may this be the story that guides us the
story that inspires us
and the story that tells ages yet to
come
that we answer the call of history we
met the moment
democracy and hope truth and justice
did not die in our watch but thrive
that america secured liberty at home and
stood once again as a beacon to the
world
that is what we owe our forebearers one
another
and generation to follow so
with purpose and resolve we turn to
those tasks
of our time sustained by faith
driven by conviction and devoted to one
another and the country we love
with all our hearts may god bless
america
and may god protect our troops thank you
america
[Applause]
you